Something big is coming to Pen Gu island.
Never give up on being awesome!
Gnarly!
Put them together for the Hang Five:...
...the most extreme team, surfing the Earth and living the dream.
They're here!
Wow, the Hang Five!
Seeing them surf made me who I am today.
What's up, little dudes?
You're the awesomest!
From Sony Pictures Animation and WWE Studios:...
JC, Undertaker, Hunter, Paige and Mr. McMahon...
...are putting Cody and his friends to the ultimate test.
This is the map to the most legendary surfing spot on the planet.
It's a surfer's graveyard.
To ride the most dangerous waves on Earth.
You gotta do more than surf it.
You gotta survive it.
This is my one big chance to get off Pen Gu and make something of myself.
They're taking them under their wings.
If you wipe out up here, you'll be a bucket of extra crispy.
Whoa man, don't eat me.
I'm not the food.
To help them overcome their fears.
I can't watch.
This is the moment we've been waiting for.
Hold on!
And discover the meaning of teamwork.
We have each other's back, no matter what.
Surf's Up 2: Wave Mania